OK, so let's unpack this.
Imagine spending your entire
working life doing something,
only to realize, like decades
later, it's a living, breathing
example of a really complex
philosophical idea you once
studied in college.
That's pretty much what happened
to the author of the material
we're diving into today at 55,
after this long career in online
reputation management ORM.
They had this huge aha moment.
It connected their daily grind,
you know, directly to Jacques
Derrida's Ini APA de ortex.
Which translates roughly to
there's nothing outside the
text.
Really powerful idea.
And what's so fascinating here,
as the author points out, is how
text expands way beyond just,
you know, words on paper.
They describe it as a sealed
system of signification.
So think about it.
It could be a pop idols whole
persona meticulously crafted
like a.
Brand.
Exactly.
Or an SEO campaign, a news
story, even even architecture.
It's all about how meaning gets
created and basically exists
entirely within that specific
sort of self-contained system.
And that's our mission for this
deep dive, right?
To figure out how this, well,
kind of abstract concept, there
is nothing outside the text,
actually shows up in our very
real, sometimes pretty bizarre
digital lives.
We're going to explore it using
this really unlikely pop culture
example and then think about
what it means for how we see
reality and how we manage our
own identities online.
It really gets to the heart of
how these big ideas underpin our
everyday online world.
OK, so here's where it gets
really interesting.
The catalyst, the thing that
sparked this whole realization
for the author?
It was this glitchy bleach
blonde YouTube idol Poppy.
Poppy.
Yeah, she became their test
case.
And the other's point is
basically, you shouldn't care
who Poppy really is behind the
scenes, right?
Because according to Derrida's
idea, none of that external
stuff matters.
Poppy is the text.
She acts like this perfectly
sealed, Immaculate terrarium.
A white cube.
Yeah, a white cube for our minds
and for the author.
She was this perfect living
mirror of what they do every
single day.
And Poppy embodies this so well.
She really is this complete
biosphere, totally self
referential.
How so?
Well, think about her
characteristics.
Those deadpan eyes, the soft
ASMR glitch in her voice, that
constant I'm Poppy repetition.
Right, that loop.
Exactly.
It all creates this perfect
semiotic feedback loop.
The source material really
hammers this home trying to find
the truth behind the curtain.
It's pointless.
Because there is no outside.
Precisely all the meaning you
need is right there inside the
loop she creates.
And the bigger insight, I think,
for all of us is how in this
digital age, erception isn't
just like reality.
It kind of is.
Reality.
It is the only reality that
matters within those constructed
boundaries.
It's the text.
OK, so if oy, is this like
perfect example of a
selfcontained white cube, how
does that abstract idea
translate to the, well, the
messy practical world of online
reputation management?
Yeah, good question.
This is the field the author's
been in for what, almost 3
decades ORMSEO their job is
literally building, tending, re
indexing, defending white cubes
for other people.
And that's what they mean by
applied deconstruction.
It's not just, you know, fixing
a bad link here or there.
It's bigger than that.
Much bigger the other talks
about it like re landscaping the
entire sealed garden.
The goal is making sure the
whole biosphere stays stable,
balanced, self-sustaining.
So that involves actively re
signifying people, almost like
controlling the inputs and
outputs that carbon eaters and
oxygen makers of someones public
identity.
To what end?
So that the algorithm, which,
let's face it, is effectively
the final reader in our age,
only sees and serves up the new
curated story.
Wow, so you're basically
creating a reality where the
unwanted stuff just doesn't
exist within that accessible
text.
That's the aim.
Which brings us to this really
great metaphor.
The author uses the duck
metaphor.
They say if your client cracks
like a duck, walk like a duck
and migrate like a duck online.
Then Google, and by extension
the world.
We'll believe they are a duck
and that flat out is the job.
It's a brilliant way to put it.
It captures how you're managing
this closed ecosystem of
perception, and it clears up a
big misunderstanding about
Derrida.
Which is that?
Nothing outside the text means
context is everything.
It's actually the opposite.
OK, I'm.
Following.
Jared, as big sort of heresy was
saying, there's no final
context, no ultimate truth
outside the system you're
looking at.
Right.
The source puts it like this.
If you can't find your answers
inside the sealed cube, you're
not reading, you're just myth
hunting.
Hunting for something that isn't
there, essentially.
Exactly.
But the challenge, and this is
crucial, the cost, comes if the
real client honks like a goose
behind the fence while you're
busy making him look like a duck
online.
That's where the fragility comes
in.
That's the crack in the white
cube.
And that fragility seems key.
This isn't like a set it and
forget it kind of thing.
Not at all, The author says.
The moment someone stops tending
the system, that perfect little
biosphere begins to rot.
The case that's in.
All that old stuff, the things
you tried to bury, mug shots,
scandals from the Wayback
Machine.
It tries to seep back in through
the cracks.
Yeah, it's like weeds growing
back.
It sounds a lot like, you know,
trying to keep your social media
perfect.
You slip up once, don't maintain
it, and suddenly that awkward
photo from 10 years ago is back.
That's a good analogy.
The author compares it to
needing blood pressure meds or
anti rejection drugs after a
transplant.
You can't just stop, you have to
show up, tend the garden every
single day or the whole system
starts to falter.
It requires constant vigilance.
Constant vigilance, and this is
where the idea of metanoia
becomes really important.
Metanoia.
Yeah, it means more than just a
surface rebrand.
It means like a genuine
transformation for that
biosphere, that online text to
actually last.
Yeah, it can't just be smoke and
mirrors.
So faking it doesn't work long
term.
Right.
Someone who's just a fraud, who
hasn't really changed, has to
keep pumping infinite energy
into maintaining the illusion
the author calls it, heading
towards heat death if there's no
real oxygen.
The smartest people the author
worked with, they're the ones
who took it as a second chance
and actually became the thing
they asked the author to build
online.
So they align their actions with
the constructed texts.
Exactly.
That's real transformation, not
just deconstruction or covering
things up.
The source has this great line
about dads saying the best dads
are often boring and cringe,
steady and present, not the
flashy ones who just throw a
Porsche at their kid once a
year.
Consistency over grand gestures.
Precisely that.
Steady, daily tending.
Like good SEO, like good ORM,
like being a present parent.
That's what keeps the biosphere
healthy and stops it from
collapsing.
It's amazing, then, to think
about the author having this
realization at 55 that their
postmodern studies from college
were like the whole source code
for their entire career.
Yeah, it's.
Quite a connection to make.
Because you often think of
postmodernism as just being
about, you know, tearing things
down, tearing the master's house
down, as they put it,
deconstructing everything.
Right.
The critique, The dismantling.
But their actual job, their
trade, wasn't just about
dismantling, the author
realized.
It was actually about building
something coherent to live in.
And that's the crucial shift in
understanding, isn't it?
From just taking things apart to
actually constructing something
stable, something self
referential.
They can stand on its own.
A strong text.
A text strong enough, as they
say, to stand up to the weather,
where all the signifiers
reinforce each other and there
are no half dug tunnels for the
rats to crawl through.
The biosphere has to be stable.
And Poppy, the YouTube idol.
Poppy taught them that
fundamental lesson, that you do
not need the brown haired
videos, the supposed real
history.
There is no archive that matters
more than the loop you hold in
the present.
In that sense, Poppy is as real
as the weepy slam poet in a dive
bar.
Maybe the author suggests even
more real.
Because she is her own
biosphere, fully realized within
its own terms.
Exactly.
Self-contained.
Self-sustaining.
So wow, we've really come full
circle back to Ilniyapada O
text.
This deep dive, I think, really
shows how it's not just some
abstract philosophical phrase.
No, it's incredibly practical.
It's a reality that governs so
much of our online identity, our
reputations, even culture
figures like Oy.
It's all about crafting and then
constantly, constantly
maintaining the text of who you
appear to be online.
And the author really stresses
that doing this work, building
and maintaining these white
cubes, it's actually a chance to
become your own biosphere.
A chance to define yourself
within that space.
But, and it's a big but, it's
fragile, the illusion, the text
is all there is, but it demands
that constant, honest tending.
If you crack open the glass, if
you let uncontrolled context
creep back in, the illusion
shatters.
Which really brings up a
question for you listening right
now.
If that online self we project
is a constructed text and
keeping it stable requires all
this effort and importantly,
alignment with our actual
actions, what does that mean for
how you present yourself online
day-to-day?
Are you tending your own
biosphere?
Yeah.
Or are you just letting the
desert wind blow through the
cracks?
Because, as the source
powerfully concludes, the best
text will rot if you don't keep
living in it every day.
Nothing outside it will save
you.